[Musique]
en attendant que les shadoks se lasse de
pomper et que le plan shadow crac et que
le plan shadoks rate les gy be sont
partis en vacances à la campagne
il en profite pour se faire de nouveaux
costumes
il faut dire qu'en ce temps là quand ils
voulaient changer de costumes les jbe
mangèrent 6-1 jbe manger des fleurs
ça me faisait un costume à fleurs si un
autre jbe préférer les petits pois
le lendemain hop il avait un petit
ensemble à pois quentin jbe manger un
jour par exemple des carottes
le lendemain par exemple rien du tout un
jour des carottes un jour rien du tout
[Musique]
ça me faisait un très joli costume rayé
et les jbe s'amusait s'amusait s'amuser
[Musique]
tandis que pendant ce temps là les
shadoks eux tombés pontet pompey il
pompelle matin ils font l après midi ils
pompaient le soir
et quand ils ne pouvaient pas ils
rêvaient qu'il pompe est ce qu'ils
revenaient exactement aux mêmes qu'à la
cosmo pompe avait été spécialement dédié
mais plus ils pompaient plus il n'y
avait rien qui sortait et le professeur
shadow qu était inquiète d'autant plus
que la planète shadoks recommencé à se
déformer et donné des signes de
désagrégation imminente
[Musique]